Etiopía es un país famoso por ser el lugar
donde nació el café aunque, curiosamente,
los etíopes no han empezado a consumir esta
bebida hasta hace unos pocos años. Durante
décadas, este país estaba entre los más
pobres del mundo. Pero si seguís VisualPolitik
desde hace tiempo, ya sabéis que Etiopía
es el escenario de uno de los más grandes
milagros de nuestro tiempo.
Exactamente, Etiopía lleva años creciendo
a ritmos del 10% interanual. Marcas de ropa
como Calvin Klein o H&M están empezando a
instalar aquí talleres textiles enormes.
Y muchísimas empresas chinas están montando
sus fábricas en las afueras de Addis Abeba.
Muchos ya se refieren a Etiopía como la China
de China ¡Pero no son los únicos! A principios
de este año 2019, Hyunday abrió su primer
centro de ensamblaje en el país. En otras
palabras, que cada vez más etíopes están
saliendo de la pobreza extrema.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no es
el auténtico MILAGRO etíope! Veréis, hasta
el año 2018, la economía estaba creciendo
pero mantenían un sistema autoritario al
estilo de China: partido único, censura y
linchamientos a las minorías étnicas. Pero
todo esto cambió, contra todo pronóstico,
con la llegada de este señor que veis en
pantalla: ABIY AHMED ALI, el nuevo primer
ministro del país. Y digo contra todo pronóstico
porque ABIY AHMED era general del ejército
y miembro del partido único, el Frente de
Liberación Popular Etíope. Vamos, que todo
apuntaba a que este hombre mantendría la
dictadura etíope tal y como estaba. Y es
donde llega aquí llega el auténtico milagro.
Porque nada más llegar el gobierno, ABIY
ha renegado de décadas de autoritarismo y
se ha propuesto convertir a su país en un
modelo de democracia para toda África. De
la noche a la mañana, eliminó la censura,
prohibió las persecuciones étnicas perpetradas
por el ejército y ha anunciado elecciones
libres para el 2020. Todo esto acompañado
de reformas económicas y un tratado de paz
con Eritrea que suena a música celestial
para los inversores internacionales. Vamos,
que si hay un candidato a premio novel de
la Paz, es el señor ABIY AHMED. De hecho,
en VisualPolitik le nombramos político del
año 2018. Pero aquí es donde llega la gran
duda. Porque, sobre el papel, las intenciones
de este líder político son impecables. Si
consigue todo lo que se propone, se convertiría
en un Nelson Mandela del siglo XXI. Pero,
como siempre decimos en este canal, las cosas
siempre son más complejas de lo que parece…
El gobernador del estado etíope de Amhara
es asesinado en un intento de golpe de estado
¡Habéis oído bien! Las transiciones democráticas
nunca son fáciles. Y más en un país donde
ya existía una élite política privilegiada
y donde tienen más de 13 grupos étnicos
distintos. Hablamos de un país enorme, con
más de 100 millones de habitantes y más
de 13 idiomas. Y todo esto supone un auténtico
examen de conciencia para ABIY AHMED. Porque
con tantísima oposición interna y tantísimos
problemas, es muy tentador volver a los métodos
dictatoriales. A fin de cuentas, para un tirano
es mucho más fácil callar a los críticos.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Hasta qué punto
ABIY AHMED va a mantener su compromiso con
los derechos humanos? ¿De verdad puede Etiopía
convertirse en una democracia? ¿O tal vez
la tentación de ser un tirano es irresistible?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
EL PAÍS DE LAS TRES REVOLUCIONES
Muchos asociáis Etiopía con los rastafaris.
Como sabéis, Bob Marley y sus amigos eran
seguidores de una religión que veneraba al
rey HAILE SELASSIE, emperador de Etiopía.
Pero, sin ánimo de ofender a los rastafaris
que veáis este vídeo, la realidad es que
el señor Haile Selassie era un monarca absoluto
que gobernó Etiopía con mano de hierro.
Sin embargo, como pasa con tantos líderes
autoritarios, el señor Selassie no murió
en la cama. En el año 1975, la guerrilla
de los DERG se hizo con el poder y mataron
al rey. Esta se considera la primera revolución
etíope. Los DERG era un grupo marxista leninista
que gobernó el país durante la década de
los 80. En estos años colectivizaron las
tierras y nacionalizaron todas las empresas
y acabaron con más de medio millón de críticos.
Conclusión: en estos años es cuando Etiopía
sufrió sus peores hambrunas. Y así es como
en el año 1991, tras una cruenta guerra civil,
el Frente Democrático Revolucionario se hizo
con el poder. Esta fue la segunda revolución
etíope ¡Pero no os equivoquéis! El país
no pasó a ser una democracia ni muchísimo
menos. Este Frente Democrático Revolucionario
era un partido comunista moderado, con una
ideología similar a la del Partido Comunista
Chino. Eso explica las relaciones tan estrechas
entre Etiopía y China y el crecimiento económico
que ha tenido este país desde entonces. Pero
atentos porque aquí viene lo realmente interesante
en esta historia.
Veréis, Etiopía es un país con más de
100 millones de habitantes y más de 13 tribus
distintas. Tribus que no se llevan necesariamente
bien entre ellas. Y por eso, la constitución
federal etíope es tan especial.
Para empezar, Etiopía es el único país
del mundo, junto a Liechtenstein, donde está
reconocido el derecho a la secesión. Es decir,
que, teóricamente, cualquiera de estas 9
regiones que veis en el mapa podría tener
un referéndum de autodeterminación y convertirse
en un país independiente.
Y por supuesto, cada una de estas tribus tiene
su propio partido político. Todos estos partidos
políticos forman parte de esa gran coalición
que es el Frente Democrático Revolucionario
Etíope. Y todos estos partidos forman parte
del parlamento. En otras palabras, que el
debate político en Etiopía no tiene nada
que ver con las ideologías. No se trata de
izquierda y derecha, o de liberales contra
conservadores sino de distintas tribus defendiendo
sus intereses.
Y diréis ¿Ha funcionado este sistema? ¿De
verdad es Etiopía un ejemplo de tolerancia
entre distintas tribus y etnias? Pues lo cierto
es que no. Para empezar, ese derecho de autodeterminación
que tienen en la constitución es papel mojado.
Cada vez que una región ha intentado separarse
del país, el ejército no ha dudado en invadirla.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, no todas las
tribus tienen el mismo poder. En realidad,
de esos más de 13 grupos étnicos, hay 3
que realmente controlan el país: los OROMO,
los AMHARA y, sobretodo, los TIGRAYS. El resto
de grupos han sufrido toda clase de violaciones
de derechos humanos. Eso incluye desplazamientos
forzados, confiscación de tierras e, incluso,
asesinatos. Por ejemplo: los somalíes que
viven en Etiopía han sufrido los ataques
continuos de grupos paramilitares. Y tanto
el gobierno como el ejército hacían la vista
gorda. Y, por supuesto, durante todos estos
años, miles de activistas y periodistas han
tenido que marcharse al exilio. Por si todo
esto fuera poco, Etiopía también estaba
en guerra con su país vecino: ERITREA. En
otras palabras: que sí, la economía iba
como la seda. 10% de crecimiento interanual,
grandes gigantes empresariales como Ethiopian
Airlines y montones de fábricas. Pero la
situación política no podía ir peor. Y
aquí es cuando Etiopía
ha vivido su tercera revolución. Ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver.
LA ROCKSTAR ETÍOPE
Os lo vuelvo a repetir: recordad este nombre
porque puede que sea premio novel de la paz
algún día: ABIY AHMED ALI. Hasta el año
2018, era lo que en política llamamos un
“apparatchik”, es decir, un hombre de
régimen. Un general que pertenecía a la
tribu de los OROMO, que como hemos dicho,
es uno de los grupos que controlan el país.
Sin embargo, nada más poner un pie en el
gobierno, ha sorprendido a propios extraños
con las reformas más ambiciosas que os podáis
imaginar. Y, creedme, esto es algo prácticamente
único en la historia. Para que os hagáis
una idea, en sólo un año, este señor ha
firmado la paz con Eritrea, ha eliminado casi
todas las medidas de censura y ha acabado
con todos esos ataques a las minorías étnicas
¿Os parece poco? Pues esperad porque no he
terminado. También ha anunciado elecciones
libres para el año 2020, ha conseguido que
pongan de presidenta a una mujer y está aprobando
las mayores liberalizaciones del país.
Etiopía instalará una red de 4G antes de
la liberalización de las telecomunicaciones
Con todo esto, es fácil entender por qué
se ha convertido en la nueva rockstar africana.
De hecho, ya se habla de la ABIYMANÍA. Y
creedme, todo lo que os voy a decir ahora
no es ninguna exageración. Ya hay grupos
religiosos que aseguran que es el mesías
enviado por Dios. Y en Eritrea, que era el
país enemigo por antonomasia, hay madres
que ponen a sus hijos el nombre del primer
ministro etíope. Y los medios del país están
viviendo un auténtico renacimiento.
La sátira florece en Etiopía
Periódicos nuevos, programas de televisión
nuevos y periodistas que regresan al país
tras años en el exilio. Las imágenes que
veis son de comedias Etíopes que se pueden
encontrar en el mismísimo YouTube. Por primera
vez pueden hacer chistes de políticos o incluso
hacer caricaturas del primer ministro. Incluso
parece que el año que viene, la televisión
Etíope tendrá su primer late night al estilo
The Daily Show. Todo esto que os puede parecer
normal en vuestro país es una novedad histórica
en este país.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque… todo
esto está muy bien cuando todos estos medios
adoran a su nuevo líder que les ha dado libertad
de expresión pero… ¿Qué pasa cuando hay
críticos de verdad? Pues atentos porque ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.
LOS RIESGOS DE LA LIBERTAD
Como dice el refranero castellano: poco dura
la alegría en casa del pobre. 2019 ha sorprendido
a los etíopes con una terrible sequía que
ha dejado a muchas regiones en situación
de hambruna. El desempleo roza el 20% y muchísimos
jóvenes están desesperados. Y por si esto
fuera poco, la vieja guardia del ejército
etíope no está demasiado contenta con esta
tercera revolución. Esto es lo que ha ocurrido
en junio de este 2019.
Un guardaespaldas mata a un oficial del ejército
etíope y a un líder regional
El presidente del estado de Amhara, AMBACHEW
MEKONNEN y fueron disparados y el procurador
general también ha resultado herido en la
capital de Amhara.
Básicamente, un militar, que pertenecía
a la tribu de los Amhara, mató al gobernador
de la región. En su opinión, Abiy Ahmed
estaba acabando con los privilegios de su
tribu. Así que organizó un golpe de estado
para separarse del resto del país. La reacción
del gobierno central no se hizo esperar.
Las fuerzas de seguridad etíopes matan al
supuesto líder del golpe de estado
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de una respuesta
militar! Durante casi dos días, el gobierno
central cortó Internet. Así, tal cual. Durante
varias horas, ningún etíope puedo conectarse
a la red. De esta forma, no había medios
de comunicación que pudieran contar lo que
pasaba ni voces críticas de ningún tipo.
En otras palabras, que parecía que la libertad
de expresión en este país iba a durar poco.
Pero si pensabais que este ha sido el único
problema para Abiy Ahmed, estáis muy equivocados.
Atentos.
Referendum en Etiopía: docenas de asesinados
en las protestas de los Sidama
¡Habéis oído bien! Con tantos vientos de
libertad en Etiopía, los Sidama, que es una
de estas tribus tradicionalmente reprimidas
por el ejército, decidió convocar un referendum.
Un referendum de autodeterminación. No es
que quieran separarse de Etiopía pero quieren
tener su propia región autónoma ¡Esto son
las cosas que pasan cuando das libertad a
la gente! ¡Que resulta que la quieren utilizar!
Y en este momento es cuando el Gobierno de
Addis Abeba dijo “pfff menuda liada, quien
me mandaba a mí meterme a moderno y tolerante
si es que, con lo bien que estábamos con
la dictadura… a ver, los Sidama estos, que
vale, que os dejo hacer el referendum pero
esperadme unos meses ¿no? ¿Cinco meses?
En cinco meses, lo que queráis”. Y claro,
los Sidama dijeron “Ya, claro, cinco meses…
¡Tu eres como los anteriores gobiernos! Mucho
decir que tenemos libertad pero luego no nos
dejas hacer referéndums!” Y así es como
surgieron protestas violentas con más de
30 muertos.
Así que ya sé lo que estáis pensando: pues
si, este tal Adiy Ahmed es más decepcionante
que la última película de Tarantino. Pues
esperad un momento porque a veces, la historia,
es más bonita de lo que parece.
Etiopía tendrá un referendum de autonomía
para la etnia Sidama en Noviembre
Exacto, parece que Adiy Ahmed está realmente
dispuesto a permitir el derecho a la autodeterminación.
Y, por el momento, parece que la libertad
de expresión se mantiene. Por ejemplo, mientras
preparábamos este vídeo, hemos podido consultar
algunos periódicos etíopes que publican
noticias en inglés. Y por primera vez hemos
podido encontrar noticias como esta.
34 muertos en los disturbios de los Sidama
Lo sé: es una mala noticia. Una noticia que
no deja en buen lugar al gobierno. Pero precisamente,
el hecho de que un periódico etíope pueda
publicar malas noticias en, en sí mismo,
una buena noticia. Por ejemplo, sería casi
imposible encontrar algo así en un periódico
chino. Para que os hagáis una idea, Deutsche
Welle, que es como la BBC alemana, ha empezado
a emitir en lengua Amhara, que es el idioma
más hablado en el país. Y mirad qué tipo
de tertulias tienen en la radio.
Discusión: el riesgo del país. Se empiezan
a oir advertencias de que Etiopía está en
peligro como país. Esto justifica miedos
de que el país entero está en peligro
De nuevo, no son buenas noticias. Y tampoco
sabemos qué se discutirá en esta tertulia
porque, lo siento, no hemos encontrado a ningún
etíope que nos lo pueda traducir. Pocierto
que si alguno está viendo este vídeo y habla
amhara, que nos escriba. Pero lo cierto es
que parece que efectivamente, hay cada vez
más libertad de expresión en este país.
Y, de hecho, Abiy Ahmed mantiene su promesa
de convocar elecciones. Por supuesto que esto
no es tarea fácil. De entrada, necesita actualizar
el censo electoral lo que implica un trabajo
titánico. Recordad que, por mucho crecimiento
que tengan, Etiopía sigue siendo un país
verdaderamente pobre. Y su gobierno tendrá
que hacer frente a muchísimos desafíos,
entre otros, el desempleo. Así que la pregunta
es ¿Podrán celebrar elecciones libres sin
problemas en el año 2020? ¿Cuántas tentaciones
nuevas le surgirán a Abiy Ahmed para volver
al viejo autoritarismo? ¿Está Etiopía preparada
para la democracia? Podéis dejarme vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, recordad que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.